I think AI will be as much of a game
changer as the internet was
the the thing that I read that scares me
the most is
if I'm a young writer now today I'm
leaning heavily on tools and templates
you know what else I'm doing start going
back to AI I'm using AI to generate
outlines I'm using AI to generate beat
sheets I'm using AI to check whether my
story structure is sound and I'm not
threatened by this I'm not afraid that
AI is going to put me out of work or
maybe I am but at least I recognize that
AI is definably three things a tool
a partner
a competitor it's not always all those
things but we can count on it being one
or another of those things pretty much
all the time
and it's not totally accurate yet from
no but it's still in its infancy but
it's not yeah it's going interesting
places it sure is it has it has solved a
big problem in my art
because all of my work is digital I
don't draw by hand
and so the question is always in my mind
where does the base image come from
and I'm very
um
I'm careful about what I take I'm
careful about how I create my images I
don't want to borrow pieces that look
like borrowed pieces
but I can say to the AI
give me a
a collection of stick figures in blue
and green and it'll create an image that
I've never seen before and never
imagined I might not want that image but
I might see it as the start of something
interesting and then it's where my piece
begins
it it's not stolen from anybody because
it was generated According to some words
that I made up so the Genesis of the
idea is the words I made up the the
words I put into the search prompt
what comes out of that if it's true AI
is something that we'll never have
existed in any form before not just a
scraped image the problem with AI right
now is that it's borrowing too liberally
from what's out there and passing it off
as original content that's not what it
is and that's copyright violation that's
a lot of problems but true AI will
respond to a sophisticated set of Search
terms
tell me a story about an astronaut
stranded on the moon
whose wife is running the mission from
mission control on Houston
and AI will give me story beats that are
very conventional according to its
understanding of what it means to be
stranded and what it means to be
separated from spouse but it's going to
give me a pretty solid platform
for a story that I just thought up in
the moment that's an example of using it
as a partner and a tool
on the other hand if my producer
can get the script without bothering to
engage me
because AI is doing that good a job then
it's competitor
this is me in my tranquility and my
objectivity saying hey everybody it's
not a good thing not a bad thing it's
just a thing that's happening and if you
want to have a good relationship with AI
whatever it becomes or anything you can
think of for that matter don't apprehend
it as a threat don't apprehend it as an
opportunity just apprehend it as exactly
what it is experience it without laying
your own judgments on top of it
interesting
nanotechnology was thought of in the
same way it was something to be feared
and something to be embraced
the Y2K bug we thought it was going to
end everything people took precautions
they got ahead of it some of it
worked some of it didn't
I think AI will be as much of a game
changer as the internet was
that the thing that I read that scares
me the most is
we are currently capable of building
with AI we're capable of building
Network platforms Global Network
platforms like Google
um
Yahoo any Global platform you can think
of that are so complex and sophisticated
that we can't control them only AI can
control them yeah
not a good thing it's not a bad thing
it's just something that's coming let's
find out
sure or the bad actor that created it
well Bad actors have used the internet
and and my career has prospered because
of the internet
so right so the good and the bad the
ying and the Yang it has no it has no
intrinsic value in and of itself it's
only how we use it and we can say that
that's true for writing comedy as well
as mentioned earlier comedy can lift up
or it can break break down it's up to
you to decide how you want to use it be
a lifter upper or knock or downer either
choice is fine it's a choice you get to
make all of creative Enterprise is
making choices anything you can think of
writing a joke telling a story painting
a picture writing a song
dancing and dance it's all Choice
everything boils down to I choose to
make it blue instead of green or red
instead of yellow or use the word what
instead of why
and
when you understand that creativity is
just making choices
and you understand that those choices
can be changed later
and that your job as a Creator is just
to make as many choices as you can as
thoughtfully and effectively as you can
then you're free then you're not afraid
of bad outcomes because you know much of
systemic choices not even good choices
not even right choices just choices
so that's where I live I live in choice